c'est un concept novateur en europe le
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines a inauguré ce mercredi 14
octobre un stade d'entraînement de haute
performance à destination des futures
pépites du golf français des
professionnels un outil pour leur
permettre de performer c'est surtout
c'est une zone qui est d'abord une zone
qui a été étudié spécialement pour la
haute performance c'est à dire
rencontrer les conditions que nos
athlètes vont rencontrer lorsqu'il joue
des compétitions sur les plus beaux et
plus difficile parcours du monde et
cette zone a repris les nos athlètes
vont pouvoir se retrouver dans les
conditions de ses plus grands tournois
un nouvel outil de travail qui a
impressionné le golfeur professionnel
jean gabriel de 86 ans aujourd'hui
l'ancien vainqueur de l'open de france
en 1969 à saint nom la bretèche
quand j'ai commencé - au pays basque
parce que je suis origines de masse base
il n'y aurait pas de practice du tout
c'était nous avions chacun aux balles de
practice très bas et on tape et bien sûr
et on allait ramasser recherché on est
en paix maintenant c'est le progrès le
stade de performance et la première
pierre d'un projet beaucoup plus large à
côté du practice de l'oise les un
dortoir pouvant accueillir 24 sportif et
si staff sera construit dans les
prochains mois un plateau performance
sera également développée à destination
des jeunes avec une école de la
préparation physique et du travail
technique avec des modélisations du
swing objectif mettre la nouvelle
génération dans les meilleures
conditions
c'est pas parce qu'on a les meilleures
infrastructures que on a forcément des
champions si je vous mets dans la dans
une formule 1 je suis pas certain que
vous soyez capable de rivaliser avec
hamilton donc il nous faut de très
belles formules 1 et on vient d'en
livrer une mais il nous faut maintenant
les pilotes qui vont pouvoir être
capable de conduire cette formule 1 au
total le nouveau stade de performance a
coûté 4,5 millions d'euros avec 60% de
fonds publics
saint quentin en yvelines et la région
font partie des partenaires sur ce
projet rendez vous dans quelques années
pour voir si ce dispositif a permis de
sortir de nouvelles pépites